the Joe Rogan experience but they were
very young you know there was a time
with my two guys we had many crocodile
rivers to cross
[ __ ] yeah Monegasque is full of
crocodiles and sometimes they would they
would ask the local community you know
whether it's safe to cross and I would
say how do they know safe to cross and
he replied once well they've made a deal
with the crocodile what do you mean
they've made a deal with the crocodile
so yeah you know they've rocked the
crocodiles have promised that they won't
eat the locals if the locals let them be
and leave them alone so you're gonna
cross that crocodile-infested River on
the hope that some contract has been
signed or some handshake give me photo
proof you know like I'm not doing and
building a raft but I find in a
different way
you know than a raft yeah even though
and we did it took us four hours to
construct a raft
yeah just to get to the other side never
knew what was in you must have been
[ __ ] your pants they target people
they do this is always three ways to
cross a river cross where the local
suggest if there's no locals across
where there's whitewater rapids if
there's not that either then yeah a raft
is the final option it's a terrifying
story about these explorers that were I
think they were on the Congo hmm and
they they were in kayaks and the guy in
front of him got attacked by a crocodile
the guy watched
the crocodile come up grab the guy flip
the kayak under and then pull pull and
then pop the kayak pops up without the
dude in it boom and then the the guys
gone scary scary snatched him out of the
kayak yeah ripped him off the popped in
Munro popped him out of the kayak and
the kayak pops up and the guys like what
in the [ __ ] he's right behind him why
this thing happened uh his boy his boy
just got eaten by a dinosaur you know
and it's crazy muddy river right it was
like [ __ ] what do you do get to shore
get that hack out you see that no we
thought we were again super vigilant we
crossed at the right places where there
was whitewater and whether you know raft
here maybe they could have been below
luckily we didn't sit and see them there
at all didn't say no no crocodiles at
all no no and it's all murky water she
can't but they can be Anakin 1961 David
Attenborough and Madagascar War sure
this guy's gotta feed it yeah what's he
bringing over to feed them I said they
were just cut it up here wonder so this
is the people that think they have a
deal with the crocodiles yeah this is
long history oh yeah muddy ask so are
they've been feeding these crocodiles
for a long time that's probably the move
feed the crocodile so the crocodiles
don't get into hunting hmm I mean yeah
they want to preserve energy if they
think they can just show up to the shore
and every day you toss them some food
yeah look help and the Crocs know
normally way that people cross and
they'll just try to stay away from human
activity normally but there are stories
of people being taken of course of
course
look how evil that goddamn thing looked
that doesn't give a [ __ ] about you know
making a deal with a croc oh yeah no and
they were laughing at me saying yeah
like course we've made a deal obviously
and I thinking I'm weird it's like but
they also believe in winches too but
it's interesting like without the real
outside world right would take away the
internet take away access to education
take away all the things that we think
of in the Western world and then in
their world like even if witches aren't
real if they operate that witches are
real they're you know they're gonna set
these like very specific patterns things
are allowed to do and things are not
they're not allowed to do and that at
least gives them this idea that carrying
that chicken around is protecting them
yeah you know the chickens gonna protect
you from the bad witches like I say and
they just keep living that like you
can't take a chance yeah they take a
chance and abandon the chicken what did
you get killed by a witch yeah yeah yeah
yeah it's stuck in these patterns
because life is so sketchy there as it
is you're surrounded by dinosaurs you're
hacking your way through [ __ ]
terrible forest it's almost to protect
them as well as younger by creating
these stories there was another one that
if a leaf falls if you're resting in the
shade it gets high in Madagascar
underneath the tree therefore leaf drops
it means there's a snake in the tree
warning you to get out from underneath
the second leaf drops its warning it's
about to spiral down
and spear through your skull and again I
might that's impossible right no no so
I'll just wind them up you know uh a
second leaf dropped and they would scan
I'd still be there likes another tree
[Applause]